Miley Cyrus shuts down pregnancy rumors  in epic fashion the 26 year old singer  who recently tied the knot to longtime  love liam hemsworth after 10 years  together i call him my survival partner  now took to social media to respond to  the multiple reports surfacing that the  pair is expecting pretty fun  Miley retweeted an outlet reporting the  news as fact writing in part I'm not  expecting but it's excellent to hear  everyone is so happy for us we're happy  for us too excited for this next chapter  in our lives now can everyone leave me  alone  [Music]  the denial comes after this photo from  the couple's wedding day surface where  Miley is seemingly covering her stomach  with her bouquet which sent fans into a  frenzy questioning her on Instagram are  you pregnant  you  [Music]